تشرف دوندو على اتمام عقدها السابع قريبا
اختارت هذا المقهى الذي تجتمع فيه مع
اقاربها واصدقائها لكونه تابعا لجمعيه
المتقاعدين فالاسعار هنا ارخص بكثير
مقارنه بالمقاهي والمطاعم العاديه
الوضع الاقتصادي يصبح اصعب مع الوقت حتى
الامور البسيطه لم يعد بالامكان القيام
بها كالخروج في نزهات كل ذلك بات مكلفا
هناك من يستطيع القيام بذلك لكن المعاش لا
يكفي
كثيرا من المتقاعدين حذوه فالعيش براتب
تقاعديا في ظل غلاء الاسعار مع ارتفاع نسب
تضخم في البلاد قد لا يكون سهلا
حيدر متقاعد بعد عقود قضاها في وظيفه
اداريه ظروفه اجبرته على العمل على هذه
العربه نتيجه ضيق الحال وعدم كفايه معاشه
التقاعدي لتامين احتياجاته
هل كنت ساعمل لو كان معاش التقاعدي كافيا
صرت في الثالثه والسبعين من العمر لو كنت
قادرا على تامين احتياجاتي هل كنت ساعمل
انا ايضا اريد ان اخرج في عطله كالاخرين
قمت بذلك مره او مرتين بدعم من ابني ولكن
مع ضيق الحال هم ايضا لم يعد بامكانهم
مساعدتي يزيد الشتاء الامر صعوبه على
المتقاعدين في ظل الحاجه الى استهلاك اكبر
للغاز والكهرباء
زادت الحكومه المعاشات التقاعديه مؤخرا
لتوفير الاحتياجات الاساسيه للمتقاعدين
لكن خبراء اقتصاد يقولون انه وبالرغم من
تراجع ارقام التضخم بدايه هذا العام
مقارنه مع نهايه العام الماضي الا ان هذه
الارقام تبقى مرتفعه
يفترض ان تكون هناك زياده في النصف الثاني
من العام لكن ذلك متعلق بقرار من سيفوز
بالانتخابات حسب الابحاث التي اجريتها
هناك حاجه لعشره الى 15% زياده مع التذكير
ان هذا حمل حقيقي على خزينه الدوله
اتخذت الحكومه في الاونه الاخيره اجراءات
عده تتعلق بالمتقاعدين من بينها قانون
التقاعد المبكر ومع ذلك يرى اقتصاديون ان
هذه الاجراءات قد لا تؤتي اكلها ما لم تتم
الموائمه بين رواتب المتقاعدين ونسب
التضخم المرتفعه في البلاد
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره انقره